madison one east side restaurant and bar
has a reason to celebrate christmas this
year they made it through the height of
the pandemic bianca holman shows us how
they're spreading some holiday cheer
haul out the holly and put up the tree
before my spirit falls again there's a
lot of christmas right this very minute
at the plate bar and grill on the east
side just how many trees fill up the
venue i believe they counted over a
hundred owner lori everett says the
over-the-top holiday decorations have
become a tradition from the patron
christmas tree stockings hunt with care
and bartender zoe in a santa hat
every inch is covered in joy including
the bathroom and they've got a reason to
be cheerful we made it through the worst
part of the pandemic but there's still
so many things that
are
not the same like there's shortages on
product
and delivery
problems so every day is
a struggle everett says their loyal
neighborhood customers help them stay
afloat and also help them expand their
jolly decor even if you're a grinch your
heart will grow three sizes counting all
the santas at the plate bar and grill
it's just calming
it's just a great atmosphere just relax
there's so much tension in the world
right now
and during the holiday season so it's
just time to relax and enjoy the view
bianca holman live local now